欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是阿伦
今天最适合做什么呢
睡觉
今天
乳球了
对不对
天气有点微凉之外呢
股市根本就没有人想要交易了
这个成交量啊
突然又降到了五六千亿啊
要不是尾盘有杀下来
可能有些人觉得有点压力
可能真的就是5000多亿的成交量而已
没有错
然后相关的这个AI的概念股门
又遇到了近期的AI风波
那个走势也很辛苦
但是说实话这些风波
古早古早以前
在这个AI发展的过程中
也常常被拿出来提押
就是说AI如果发展过速的话
大家是不是不要军备竞赛投这么多
但是近期因为有发生了
AI自己去当駭客
跑到别人家
结果呢
管他的那个主人
根本就不知道
后来才发现
对
所以就
真的很夸张
那个周末是连续
三四家的龙头
全部都来发炎
同意放缓
所以看起来应该是有压抑
一段时间了
然后在周末一口气爆出来
就好像我们养了什么宠物
结果跑出去
到别人家吃饱回来
我们都没发现
只觉得他越来越胖这样子吗
是这样吗
不是带三五个小孩回来
外面剩下三五个小猫
所以到底像这个礼拜
有AI的利空
也有生息的压力
是不是最后要解压缩的时候
我们就来看了
要怎样才能解压缩
我们收到压缩档
都点两下
它就会展开
要按右键按解压缩
对吗
但是里面搞不好
一大包是可以拿来用的东西
是这样讲是没错啦
所以看礼拜四能不能
把那个压缩解下来
是
对啊
然后看一下
量能激动了吗
最终利空测试
AI降速连准会生息
是
然後又資金又大風吹
資安要買龍頭
可是資安好難容納大資金
等一下來聊一下怎麼幫大家做宣布
我們先來看一下最近發生什麼事情
在週末的時候
這個阿莫迪 安斯洛普克執行長
直接發了一個3800字的長文
說我們應該要讓AI的發展速度降慢
這個AI圖是安斯洛普克做得上
為什麼他像花美男
然後只有馬斯克像本人最近年紀也比較大為什麼只有他像本人然後馬斯克直接在Twitter上也引用了他的文然後說agree
然後他就說阿莫迪是對的
奧特曼也同意
這樣我們可能open AI的IPO案
會稍微往後延一下
所以目前來說這幾個大佬
都在想要讓AI的發展放緩
我覺得不太對勁
三人成虎
一定必有詭計
所以這個川普也出來講話了
川普大哥
對 川普是大哥
這個黃仁勳最近在公開場合有一個演講
在Podcast 他錄Podcast
然後這個川普就打電話進來了
對 就說這個都中國的陰謀
真的在 阿公的陰謀嗎
對 然後他也說
不是我這樣 是他真的在上面這樣講
大家可以去看他的影片
然後他說
美國不能在與中國的AI競賽中退讓
所以他是呼籲不要放緩發展
對 他都不可以
沒錯 因為以前大家可能是
核彈數量在爭第一名
現在算力最多就是第一名
當然
所以確實以川普的角度來講
他肯定是不想要放緩的
因為他想要美國一直
就是全球地位領先
所以目前看起來有點尷尬
但我覺得市場會比較是
針對這個去做反應
因為大家都覺得你AI要放緩
那你是不是資本支出會縮水
那資本支出縮水是不是AI不發展
那台灣是不是因為AI而起
又要因為AI而弱
所以整個半導體類相關的
美國或台灣其實近期的表現
都比較辛苦一點點
所以AI概念股跟這個記憶體
在昨天的表現都非常辛苦
昨天美國的四大指數
大概都跌1%內就非半跌5%
因為看一下整個跌幅都比較誇張
然後美國的資安股表現就很強
台灣最近的安控啊
或者是資安啊
或者是軟體股
近期的表現就比較強
因為大家說網路安全
好 這個是其中一個近期最大的事件
再來另外一個呢
就是這禮拜三到禮拜四凌晨最大的事件
好 但是其實上禮拜五啊
我本來以為差不多啦
因為大家看到CPI沒有什麼很嚴重的反應還漲了
是
但為什麼這禮拜又重新拿回來變成一個議題了
其實它公佈CPI的時候
股市是先煞後拉
對 可是先煞那過程中
其實利率決策就已經拉到八成九了對啊 那就是這樣啦對啊 就要升啦然后石油价格又破百啦对啊 破百就93.5%就放给它烂这样子对对对对
所以目前来说
这个以Fedalwatch的市场押注来讲
基本上升息应该是蛮明确的事情
但是现在有一个论点
就是所谓的鸽派升息
什么意思
就是预防性升息
是啦 是有这样想
升了之后呢 叫什么
叫利空出镜
对啊
这行情就会活起来了
有一派是这样讲法
但我觉得不管是哪一派
反正现在很明确了
成交量萎缩了
那萎缩的重点就是在于
联准会利率决策后
譬如说礼拜四
礼拜五那个成交量
能不能开始放出来
放出来才有涨或者是跌
所以目前来说我觉得
升息如果是
大家心里已经有预期了
那大家可以去思考的是
真的升下去之后
会不会是迎来一个
短线的利空促进
那至少大家可能觉得
不确定性结束了
有没有机会把资金重新投入股市
那再另外一个呢
就是石油价格
对啊 因为一直在百元以上了
我们前两集还在讲
说会不会破百会不会破百
结果它就站在百元上了
那目前看起来石油价格
已经连续三到四天的时间
都在百元之上
这个对于大盘来讲
或者说对于科技股来讲
就会比较有压力一点点
通膨嘛
那另外一个呢
昨天美国不只是30年起
连10年起都一度占上了5%的殖利率
其实蛮赞的
就是会觉得
如果你今天买一个
无风险资产
而且这是十年
它两年的也4%5%4%6%
两年的就风险很低了吧
更低了
这个是资产通膨吧
我放进去就5%
以前我们在拼的是
高股息要5%以上
所以目前看起来
我觉得这个数字
也是对于股市来讲
是一个蛮明确的压力
最后我们看到大盘
大盘近期股市
因为我们在上礼拜
或上上禮拜来跟大家讲
就是短线要看10日均
长线要看20日均
那不好意思
这个在昨天跟上礼拜五呢
全部都跌破了
对
没关系你没来不算
不算是不是
这里10日均线嘛
周五的时候跌破
这里20日均线嘛
都跌破了
但是到现在是收复不回来
今天是跌破月线
是的
所以目前看起来呢
以我们常讲的这一段的惯性周期
多方的惯性
就結束了
對 但是現在沒有轉空
我問你有這樣會像M頭嗎好像每次都在問這個其實我覺得不會不會 為什像M头如果真的M头这个应该要从这里开始画这样会比较像那也很像啊
这不会啦
这没有很像
对对对
目前来说我们关注的是这一段
对
那现在已经来到这个地方了嘛
所以观察几个重点
第一个昨天有拉脚
所以昨天低点很重要
452.0左右
452.0到454.0
然后呢
如果这边真的跌破
大家记得喔
可能就来回撤这个前低的平台
这平台是在442.0
也就是说如果跌破
可能还有1200点的空间
那目前来说都还没有转空
因为这里新低还是高前低
这里新高也是高前高
也就是说真的要转空
这个低点会做跌破
那只要这边跌破呢
大家可能就
风险意识要稍微再拉高一点
现阶段我们把它归类在
这个成交量都在走萎缩的过程
是一个量缩整理的状态
那当然比较不舒服啦
所以目前没有偏空
但短线上还是在整理结构的
那就看我们整理完
礼拜四礼拜五
有沒有一些激情人
能夠稱為全部均線也好
迎來跟紅K表態也好
那就有機會在這邊
重新的一個打底
就在一個足底
那另外貴買的部分
基本上除了年限之外
全部均線跌不跌破
那目前來說就是
之前跟大家講
它就是一個箱形整理
所以這個低點沒跌破之前
它就是在區間做震盪
那就會比較沒有這麼緊張了
如果這裡真的跌破
就要比較深一點點
对 所以目前看起来
贵买虽然跌破了一些均线
但还没有让它的整个
箱形整理去做转折
所以目前是不用太紧张的
这个低点跌破
大家可能在操作上
就要有一些防范的措施了
譬如说要有一些避险部位
或者说把一些手上的资金
再重新收回来
等于有一个新的好形态出现
再重新做介入
可是你左侧的想法
就会觉得很珍惜这种回撤的机会
对 因为基本面的状况
非常好啊
是
對啊 所以一旦回撤
感覺上對我們這種
比較在意所謂價值面的人來說
好像就是機會的到來
對 所以我覺得
以我的角度來講
我就覺得 因為你右側動能
對 形態還在就可以做
但是形態不在
我都會建議等形態轉好再做
機率比較好
沒錯 沒錯
我覺得都可以
因為像我自己一些
ETF的部位也是
邊疊邊賣
對
好 再來我們看到台積電
台積電這邊
原本一度創反彈的
箱形區間突破
但會碰這一個高點沒有過
沒有過就算了
它還直接跌回到箱形區間內
是 對
所以目前臺機店又回到
這個區間內受震盪了
那如果大家把台積電的
這個K棒再拉大一點點
你可以發現它整個震盪
至少一季了
就在高檔震盪一季以上
那目前來說
成交量也都是
跟這邊相比
都是呈現一個大幅度萎縮的狀態
所以台積電
目前也沒有太明確表現空間
那就看什麼時候成交量放出來
同時往全支股做移動
才有機會做表現
另外一個就台達電
今天它跟別人長不一樣
因為它前面也跟別人長不一樣
他今天忽然反攻了一下
是的 因為他有傳出募資
也結束了
所以有一些小反應
不過這個反應大家記得
這個地方跟這個地方
還有這個地方
頭頭低
沒錯 這個地方哪裡
這個地方就是季線
季線壓著它
是的 也就是說台達電要好
首先第一關這個不能破
第二關先站回季線再說
後面才有機會挑戰前高
挑戰2000塊
甚至去挑戰前面歷史新高
因为目前给的
大摩给的那个目标价
还是在很高的位置
但目前股价确实比较不整齐
那我们先一步一步来
先回季线再看这个地方
然后形成一个多方的格局
然后再去挑战牵高
所以台大电目前来说
可能还是要再努力一下
好 当然这个是以动能的角度
对不对
如果是以就是越跌越便宜的想法
台积电应该就是一个代表
没什么问题的
台大电如果它能指纹
因为其实大家怕的是
台大电会不会再去侧底
对
如果它能指紋的话
事实上也来到了
以明年来看
相对合理本益比的时候
比较便宜的时候了
好所以刚刚我们讲的是
为什么现在盘面特别的闷呢
这礼拜有一些事件要去克服
但是有没有可能像解压缩一样
一解开里面是一个百花齐放的
其实AI不缺力多
所以现在的话压抑
我们应该要把握现在的时机
但最近盘面上
如果说以动能派来讲
就是资安类骨了
資安類股感覺上獲利很好
可是成交量很小
艾倫等一下會教你
怎麼樣安全的操作資安類股
好 來吧
我們最近這個
不管是美國還是台灣
有一個族群特別的亮眼
這幾天
沒錯 我們有分一些細族群
包含像是安控 安全監控的
不然算是資訊安全的
還有一個就是軟體股最近這幾個族群非常的強勢那為什麼呢因為OpenAI在里面有一个Hocking Face发动自主网路攻击好 他被OpenAI攻击
对
他是一个社群平台被攻击了
没错
好 那再来另外一个呢
就是Anthropic
他有对Ruby James
然后直接就为了要进去里面
他直接病毒侵入人家
那这个东西是人类没有给他指令的
他自主觉得这样子做
會拿到她想要的東西
但是她手段中間過程
她是選擇比較
我們不希望這樣做的方式
就像是以前有部電影
就是女主角喜歡男生
她就拿到她的鑰匙之後
就跑到她家幫她整理家務
然後又偷偷離開
然後男生回家的時候
就發現怎麼家那麼乾淨這樣子
恐怖嗎
滿恐怖的
善意的
不行
我自己整理
好 也就是說
大家對於網路安全這一塊
怕了吧
有点怕 蛮恐怖的
你笑很开心
对
好 所以现在在讨论
AI有进入了一个
短时间
不知道长时间会不会这样
从AI的基础建设发展
转到了AI安全网络
应该要怎么去做建立
也就是说现在
AI发展的速度已经快到
一些可能政策
或者说防护措施
是跟不太上的
那现在大家马上就回来
检视这件事情
所以这个Crowstrike
最近的表现就直接创一个新高
回答股价就一根
两个跳空缺口
這個是一些資安股代表
跟目前AI股的代表
反而是對比了
沒錯 所以目前來說
整體來講大家都在討論
怎麼樣在網路上
可以得到一份安全感
好 那當然黃文勳
我們剛好說
黃文勳其實還是堅持
去要持續發展的
對 還接到川普的電話了
沒錯 沒錯
OK 那可是台灣的資安股
其實很雜
然後個股很多
是 就小型股很多
是的 因為很多成交量
是真的很小啊
几十张的
所以然后我就会觉得
这个族群会比较
未来会不会有长线一个大波段
我觉得不一定
因为短线现在我们刚刚有提到嘛
现在成交量萎缩
市场缺乏一个这个主流
或者是缺乏一个题材
那现在题材是什么
就是这些东西嘛
所以近期的表现非常强势
那我们就稍微来看一下
就后面有没有哪一些是可以
因为这个族群真的非常大
然后很多是有一些名不见经传的
所以我們有去看一下
也可能在這些領域裡面
哪些龍頭
或者說哪些毛利是比較好的有幫大家列出來好 但大家如果有印象今天涨停的这两家就是上一波资安软体股在涨的时候说实话比较活泼的股票
滑金滑红资
那时候都连续锁涨停
因为他们的成交量不大
就好容易锁
可是这个族群里面
也有那种获利
超过一个资本额的好公司
是的
其实还有一堆
其实像以前那个大众
其实基本面也很好
也涨过一大堂
那京城大家可能就比较熟悉
台湾大
对 没错
那不过呢
今天帮大家讲的
就是01
01它是比較偏向代理的
它是代理了一些軟體的工具
包含了這邊微軟的
然後等雲端的平台跟工具
有一些訂閱跟軟體授權的營收
是就是開訂閱啦
在開訂閱的方式
那不過01的基本面它是比較偏好的
而且它比較成熟一點點
然後股價或者是整個公司的表現
是比較成熟一點
那目前來說
這個成熟我不知道在現在到底好
好不好
因为大家现在一标就是想要
一字锁一字锁一字锁
那最近一字锁的一些个股
都是比较小型的
稍微又再更小一点点
不过呢
如果是大家真的是
对于AI这个长线上是
网络安全有疑虑的
或者是说它是一个
基本面比较好的
那01它基本面确实是还OK的
那不过呢
股价技术面上
在昨天出现了一个天亮
对
这个这两天蛮多都涨这样
而且它是黑K棒或是上影线
嗯
所以呢大家可以去注意几件事情
第一个它是来到前高附近嘛
还有这边
可能在前面有些套牢的人
在这边做一个解套的卖压
那不过呢现在多方趋势是还在的
那今天呢碰五日均线又愿意收缴
所以它还在全部均线之上
有些说呢这一个大量位置啊
就会是短期要关注的换手量
如果这个地方收盘价能够去做一个突破125块
那就是换手成功哦
那到时候再去做介入
其实我觉得不会太迟
因为趋势还在嘛
那你这边大量之后
隔天还是愿意收红
还是在全部均线之上
所以显示下方是愿意
有人做接手 做换手
那要换手成功
这个大量就要做突破
所以这个高点只要做突破
趋势就还有向上的空间
这个是低档01的部分
老牌的啦
二几年来都有配股息
是的
2027年EPS
有机会挑战到9块左右
所以目前
玻璃很好啊
是的
所以目前本益比
其实也不算高
好 再来另外一个呢
就是中华资安
它这个长得真的超诡异的
平常是
就是我講幾十張的那種
對 然後所以它一千多張就會看成是一個歷史天亮是的 可是你可以注意它的毛利率是47%是高的对 是高毛利率而且它有一些官股的色彩那2025年相关的这个SOC
长约监控
首度长过51%
续约率超过了九成
所以它有一个非常稳定的底层现金流
也就是说这种个股
在还没有这种利多出现之前
第一个它成交量没有很大
但第二个它基本面很好
所以比较偏向存股的方向
但现在动能有拉出来了
当然今天
还有很多什么安基资讯
其实都是跟资安比较明确的
相关的个股
那今天全部都开高走低
反而是软体股
可能比较没有沾到边
今天的表现比较强劲一点
所以中华资安
一样跟刚刚提到的那个01一样
这里首次爆了一个大量
爆大量过程中要干嘛
就是看能不能换手成功
也就是说这边
已经要先做一个
缩链均线乖离的动作
那缩链乖离完
如果均线跟上有一个动能
能够让它带通去突破前高
这里趋势应该就还有下一段的机会
这个是大家回去可以去观察的
也就是说明后两天
大家不用急着介入
等均线跟上
然后等看这个高点
能不能去做一个消化
到时候量价
如果都还是维持一个出量的状态
再去做介入就好了
对 那长线上来讲
它其实比较偏向
就是买着
然后就稳稳的一个公司
是 好 它就叫资安嘛
中华资安
其实我觉得感觉上
有点像军工
就是很久很久很久都不发动
可是有时候一发动
真的是连续性的大涨
我觉得软体资安股
就很容易让人家
期待一大波的涨势这件事
而且它很容易就
开盘就一之锁
你想买
那也是要三五根
他看有没有机会打开
对
所以我觉得资安
大家就稍微再观察一下就好了
这个就是之前大标的
干颜股滑金
滑金
它不是获利那么好
可是却很标
没错
它前一阵子呢
这一段时间
那个成交量
就基本上就是没有量
但是到这三天量能全部都放出来
那华晶呢
它是目前有一些资安的法规提高
跟勒索病毒防护升级
中断客户会对一些零性炎结构
跟云端备份资料的资本支出
会维持一个成长
那目前呢
企业有推动深层式AI地端落地的时候
需要仰赖这种SI厂商进行
高阶伺服器的那种部署
对也就是说
它其实确实是有在做这些事情
那不过呢
我都回到一样的逻辑
因为短线上三根
就30%了
30%现在在讲的是AI的不好
需要网络的好
所以在找
到时候如果这些
那一些利空 那一些
FED升息完了
成交量拉起来了
AI回归主流了
那大家要记得
这个资金要从哪里抽
也是从这些个股抽
也就是说我会不建议用追的
但是当资金重新轮回到AI的时候
这个会开始有资金的外移
开始走回落
那如果你还是觉得这个题材
长线它应该还是一个关注的重点
就趁那个时候回落在布局就好
因为已经涨上根了
我在这边叫大家买
好像也怪怪的
好 可是这个也是我观察自然股
或是说软体股里面
蛮重要的指标
因为它就是以前的腰股
说实话
没错
所以我们可以去注意到了
技术面上当然底部确立了
那当然这几个地方
都还有一些压力要去做消化
所以来到这个地方
那已经短线又涨三根
就大家不用急着追
但是大家可以知道
有这档个股放入你的自选单
刚刚出现了一个资金轮动的状况
有走回落
那回落过程
当然均线都上完了
它如果启动一些支撑的效果
启动一些有机会在新的一段
我们再去把握那段行情就好
现在大家都知道
其实有一些软体股
包含像华金是强势的
大家就记得就好了
好 其实也可以拿来做一些训练
为什么呢
因为像我之前也是在看军工的时候
刚发动一两根的时候
想说每次都是一日行情
就最后拉出来一大段
我觉得资安和软体股
就给我也是同样的感觉
大家不妨用技术形态去锁定一下
尤其是之前的小妖股
就是华红资 华金
有在发动
那可以回头去看那些
一年可以赚七八块
甚至一个资本额的公司
它光是殖利率保护
都还算蛮甜的
当然如果对今天
所有的资料图卡
想要免费索取的话
欢迎订阅一下
赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们会放在首页的贴文栏里面
让大家索取
那广告回来我们有一个
从来没有访过的大来宾
他今天会来讲
他到底为什么会入这一行
他也曾经被诈骗过
但后来用非常用功
每天手画线图
累积出一套非常厉害的投资法则
待会来欢迎他
欢迎回来赵花
欢迎说
你在看电影或漫画的时候
你会不会从中就误导了一些
投资的心得
或是那个内容特别吸引你
我从这个兴趣
打麻将学的也蛮多的
对
因为其实他们都是一样的东西你要有纪律氣不好不要出手對不對 氣好要趁追擊那其實是有一點道理我是看電影的時候真的特別喜歡裡面有
關於財經的橋段
像最近Netflix有重新
把一個老的片上架
叫刺激1995
我本來以為那是一個冤獄的片
結果裡面的那一個主角
也是有財經的頭腦
對 還有像之前什麼
華爾街之狼啊
大麥控啊
好看
華爾街之狼不是所有
少年古神的夢想
其实我这礼拜才有讲花的节制
我自己的频道
突然
所以今天我们的来宾
他就是以前从看电影
开始有一些对投资的想像
而且他会帮你把卖
我们先来欢迎他
就是骨科大夫龙医生Eason
主持人好 观众朋友大家好
我是骨科大夫Eason
Eason第一次来上我们的
《召化爱伦说》
我们今天要把你的身家
把你起底没有
起底沒有
起底
因為骨科大夫他叫大夫嘛
所以呢叫做
人心良述
妙手回春
怎麼樣會有取這個綽號
這個名字的想像呢
就是我現在週二都有固定在節目
幫投資朋友解盤
每一次大概100多個問題
見證是不是
對 問問題
都問免費的
對 今天晚上又有
好 今天晚上就有嗎
對
先看我們再去問可以嗎
對 8點鐘開始
就每個禮拜
大概都有100多個問題
以上
那就是一年下來
其實我看很多
大概散物朋友同比
大概就是賺的抱不住
賠的砍不掉
盤整盤一直上下刷洗
然後呢
真正大趨勢都沒有跟住
大概問題就那幾個
所以投資朋友
你如果我大概看
你三四個月對賬單
我就知道說
問題可能會輸在哪裡
對 所以就是
那時候一直幫大家見證
一開始我還每天
然後後來就是實在是
負荷量太大了
所以就變成每收一次
後來就是
補合待服
那其中有一個原因是
因為那時候YouTube
剛開始要做頻道
然後在想說
到底要取個什麼名字呢
那時候有一個YouTube很紅
叫李柯太太
對 然後想說
取個諧音
古柯大夫好像不錯
好 我知道了
那你幫我看一下好不好
這是我這三四個月的對象談
是不是應該就直接見證
好 所以是有這樣一個前提
好 有興趣的朋友
看完理財檔
就再去見證好不好
你跟我們電視播出的時間
但是幫別人治病之前
其實谷柯大夫以前也有過很茫然的時候對啊 因為剛畢業不知道做什麼然後那時候大家知道我唸資管然後一開始有當過工程師
也有當PM
然後後來覺得資管
這好像就是工程師
我們韓文裡有一句話就是說
城市寫得好 要飯要到老
就是你看現在其實寫真是
都可以被Anthor Peak
被很多AI取代
對 我那時候其實就是覺得說
做這件事情好像是浪費時間
我那時候有個同事
就是寫每一段層次很厲害
寫Excel 寫VBA很厲害
然後我就想說我到底要不要花
還要去進修
然後花時間去弄這些層次
我想說以後應該會不會就有
電腦可以取代
結果果然在2025 2026開始
就是越來越大量的AI去取代了
後來其實當完在軟體公司之後
那又去當了很多
做自己興趣的事情
譬如我當過職業魔術師
當過一年
職業的魔術師
你還不是在達人秀表演魔術而已
對 我也當過職業
職業魔術師去那種什麼
各個場子表演
然後收費那一種
對 一場可能大概幾千塊這樣
小友 行親家
那時候啦
就是名氣不大的
大概就幾千塊這樣子
因為也過得蠻辛苦的
後來就想說
是不是要找一些什麼方式
可以去讓自己收入更多一些
然後其實對股票就蠻有興趣的
因為我其實大學就是賣股票
那時候可能就是當作固定存錢
然後也不知道
什麼去正確的去學習
就亂買
那個時候其實我們
學習管道很封閉
就是可能都聽消息
電視上面可能也是就是
投顧老師
其實從小我們家裡
我爸媽也有在做股票
我就看到我媽
我每天回到就看到
那時候藤古老師都很激動
每天都講的口莫焚黑
對 口莫焚黑
然後我沒回到家
就看到他看那個
然後我爸也是有買股票
然後覺得這個好像很神奇
一買一賣
按一下按鈕好像就有錢進來
後來真的進入市場之後
發現根本不是這麼一回事
其實學問水很深的
後來就一直去做研究
我剛出社會的時候
其實這個還
就是去學一些投資理財
然後認識一些朋友
然後就有朋友跟我說
我介紹你一個商品
固定領席的
然後每一年大概就8% 9%而且一單位要這個五萬十萬美金起跳大家有沒有聽起來很熟悉有沒有怎麼這兩年有發生過啊你有沒有聽到這種類似的話術的話
那我跟你講你要這個
全身的神經要緊繃起來
因為這種固定配息
然後感覺好像很安全
尤其是錢又回到國外的話
那我當時就是中了這個招
因為當時其實剛入行
然後沒有什麼研究
然後就想說好像穩定配息不錯啊
那他也不是那種暴利
也不是一年十幾二十趴
我就想說就用這個房子去借了
15萬美金就投進去了
那一開始一兩年
還有穩定的一個配息
後來就拿不回來了
就其實現在反詐騙很多
我們當時也是那個環境很封閉
大概十五十六年前
那所以當時就是這個
算是對當時的這個資金
還不小的一個衝擊
那所以後來也就開始
認真的研究股票
然後認真的去學一些
學一些籌碼等等的
學一些這個產業的訊息
你不要看現在的資訊很發達
這一套就是說
你要有10萬美元才能投
然後年息大概9% 10%
到現在我都還有朋友上當
還是有話
這一套真的歷久不出來
從馬多夫以前那時候
193幾年那是最開始
那個叫龐氏騙局
它就是基本上後金補錢金
所以我覺得現在
大家可能都有詐騙的
這個觀念是比較多的
我覺得大家一定要去注意
這個血和錢不要隨時便便的就交出去
重點是不要投資自己不懂的東西
是 好 後來你就變成很用功的在學習
對不對 而且剛剛也特別聊到
你可能有很多種學習方式
像你自己會自己畫每天的K棒之外
你看電影都會想到怎麼樣做投資
對 好 那這個K棒是我
就是後來下定決心自己學習之後
然後跟這個一個
雖然以前老一輩的主力大戶
就每天跟他在VIP室裡面研究
然後他就教我
你要練盤感是不是
你就畫這種圖圈
我今天有帶來
我可可畫了非常久的一段時間
哇塞 等一下
這是什麼
這個是每一天畫一根K棒是不是
每一天嗎
它是用價格去做
每一天在方格子上畫
這個我只有聽過
我還沒
等一下 這有點多
艾倫幫忙捲一下
那個攝影大哥幫忙拿一下
這可能要捲到門口
這很長啊 反正就是
這幾天的啊
這個應該畫了有大概兩天
這是兩萬元
家裡還有更長
就一直畫畫到去年沒有再畫
因為畫到都老花眼了
畫15分鐘眼睛就痛了
你可以叫AI畫
對
所以叫每天畫一根K棒
價格有到
它是沒有
不是看時間的
它是看價格
就是價格有達到就畫一根這樣子
價格有達到就畫一根這樣子
價格有達到就畫
價格的轉折線
轉折線
對
每天這樣畫
從這畫多久 十幾年
我從
對應該有十幾年
十幾年 從剛開始
非常用功的畫
對 那時候就每天還看
股票看十幾個小時
是 每天看十幾個小時
難怪眼睛不舒服了
眼睛都畫到不舒服了
很用功耶
對
你有畫過嗎
有
你有畫過
你有這麼用功
有
那個時候
那時候其實那一套蠻流行的
找聖杯啊
你可以K棒啊
給你四個價格
然後你就透過這四個價格
去画K棒
然后去感受他那个涨跌
有什么样的依据
是 链盘感
那你现在还有在画吗
现在没画 当然没有
Eason可以坚持到前一年嘛
我大概十几年前就没画了
那你没有坚持过啊
这个是很用功的一个证明
对 这个是链盘感
然后就是让自己更熟悉盘面的脉动
那其实找一些题材
我会看电影或打电玩里面
其實都很多未來的題材
像我們以前小時候有那個
那個叫什麼
霹靂車李麥克這樣就知道
那個就是
影集啊
對手錶按一按
車子就會跑過來
所以那個時候我們小時候
電視也不多
那時候就很有印象
電動車嘛
是特斯拉
對當特斯拉出來的時候
我們就知道說
這個東西不一樣了
那特斯拉當時呢
這個真正開始有突破
是在2019年
那時候它突破量產地域
開始可以順利的量產
然後他在上海有超級工廠出來
更是關鍵
後來搭配到了疫情
無限QE讓整個資金
往這種比較高本益比高成長類股
去做一個比較偏投機的
這樣的熱度交易
然後到了2021年
他也是全球電動車銷量的冠軍
那個時候他佔全球新車一成
全球其實非常多的廠牌
光是特斯拉就佔一成
那他這一波2019到2021
大概總共上漲了34倍那我當中其實也吃到一個不小的波段了所以其實這種科技上市如果又是新的領先的科技
我覺得大家都可以去多注意一下
後來就是在輝達
開始2023年爆紅
輝達我們以前有在組電腦
它的一個顯卡都是最高端的
最高級的
你要打電動
然後要一個就是畫面要最漂亮
然後幀數要最快
那一定要用輝達的顯卡
那就在2023年
TrackGPT開始爆紅
我那時候就覺得這個東西
跟以前的電腦不一樣
因為我們以前
不管你用Windows
這個Win95到98到2000
到Windows7、8、10
Windows再怎麼進化
它一樣是input
計算之後output
就只是畫面漂亮一些些
然後算得更快一些些
那處理的方式其實是完全一樣
可是在聊天機器人出來之後
我就覺得這東西不一樣
因為AI其實未來可以像這樣代理式的成長
那後來當然故事大家都知道
AI伺服器
GB系列
Blackware有放量
然後包括它的業績持續的成長
那甚至還有未來的主權AI
還像現在的代理人的AI
所以AI在當年2023到2025
也上漲了14倍
那我同樣的當中也賺了不少的倍數
所以我覺得在目前來說的話
我們先看
當時特斯拉就是
不管是他在這個獲利創新高
上海廠交車以及在納入S&P500
那他的這個波段下跌
這一段他也跌75%
真的很誇張
因為他一直沒有很明確的獲利剛開始
對那這一段就是
他在這個暴力升息過後
很多高本益股股下修
可是你看這種即使他的
這個很多可能還是靠補助
或者是他的這個
股價大幅度拉回之後
其實後面還是創新高了
到後來他跟川普麻吉麻吉的時候
這股價還是回到歷史新高
所以我覺得這種科技類股
像其實META之前暴跌過
真的有這種暴跌的時候
只要他的這個產業
沒有太特別變化的話
我覺得大家你是可以
把一些這種閒錢
去做這種長線的投資
因為美股的波段
常常跑得比台股
還要來得更久
那全球的這種科技業
其實主要還是看美股的顏色
那再回答的話也是
他其實當中
不管是營收炸裂
Blindwell登場
他還一拆時過等等的
他在關稅那個時間點也掉了四成股價最高點幾乎快要腰斬可是到後來它是首加突破5兆美元市值的公司
那我認為其實現在輝達
因為已經市值越來越高了
所以它的一個爆發性
可能不如以往
所以我現在又
開始關注一個新的題材
就是SpaceX
太空題材的這個電影
大家有看過嗎
好 我覺得你真的也算是
馬斯克的信眾之一了
特斯拉買的真的叫做一個信仰
那當然跟車子相關的
未來性的電影很多
太空的也很多啊
對啊 對
所以大家可能可以預料到
未來可能會
可以飛到月球去啊
月球已經是小case了
對 火星會不會殖民啊
是
以及太空AI等等的
那不管是Space
它這個衛星準備越發越多了
然後包括它的這個筷子
把火箭夾回來
那個絕對是
讓成本大幅度下降
然後讓未來這個火箭
發射可以商轉重要的一個因素
那包括其實未來手機的一個
直接聯網
這個對於電信營運商
可能就要出於是不是有些衝擊
包括各國也要開放
在烏二戰爭之後
這個地圍道衛星
開始大家逐漸注意到它的一個重要性
那太空AI部分
我覺得可能是在更遠一些些
就是說要在這個衛星軌道上面
計算之後再傳回來
那我覺得這個可能是比較長期
那我覺得短期可以看到
再次在跟各個軍用的這個部分
有持續性的這樣收入
以及在手機的這個聯網的部分
那台灣不知道什麼時候
也可以有這樣子一個低軌道微信
等於屋角落
那全 甚至在飛機上面
都可以實際有這樣子一個網路
所以接下來我覺得
可以去注意一下
今年非常多的低軌道微信題材
像是在 Amazon
也要這個正式去做一個啟用
以及在歐洲的 OneWeb
等等的一個擴建
好 但是這樣的題材
它有时候跟获利不见得
能够马上联动在一起
所以它非常仰赖着
就是你很相信
在一个很长线
在你的有生之年
这件事情它会被实践对不对
对 我觉得
就大家的资金也是有限的
然后注意力也是有限的
是 注意力有限
对 真的注意力有限
每天花这么多的一个端倫
或是很多这样
会让我们分心的事情
我觉得现在都要尽量
把注意力集中
专注在特定的产业
或是特定的这个事情上面
那低伟大惠星當然台股的代表之一
就是聖拿科聖拿科目前可以看到最近籌碼面都不錯投信在低檔做一個加碼那8月的支撐大概就在這個地方等一下我們後面會講一個賺賠比的概念
它這個地方就是賺賠比
還不錯的概念
往下的風險可能只有一些些
那在5到7月
它為什麼拉回這麼多呢
主要是因為它的客戶的設計調整
好像之前AI有調整過軍熱片
或是什麼CPU規格調整等等之類
這種類似的題材
那它是真的受到客戶影響
所以營收看起來有些掉下來
可是8月已經復活了
8月份開始
月增40%
年增93%
那包括今年來說的話
它第五道衛星的比重
會提升到77%
所以等於說它完全就是
跟第五道衛星掛鉤了
所以估計明年 EPS
應該可以來到37塊
後年就可以來到62塊
所以我覺得這個位置
已經開始有法人認為
是有吸引力的位置
所以我認為這個地方
即使不是最低也不遠了
但是大家可能就要有耐心一些
因為它跟SpaceX
跟地圍外星會是相對的連動
那我覺得後續看
在它有沒有切入到其他歐洲
其他的這樣子一個衛星的題材
好 如果說今天像這種SpaceX
它可以開始重新往上走的時候
可能大家的本夢比空間
就比較有機會拉出來了
對不對 因為現在美股跟台股
剛好我們錄影的今天
都是一個比較悶盤的狀況
所以就等這個所謂的本夢比
再次的把它拉開來
對 我覺得投資很重要的一個
我覺得我自己認為的一個概念就是
你要去知道說
你進場的風險在哪裡
然後你賺賠比怎麼樣
風暴比怎麼樣
所以我覺得
你想要有這樣子的獲利
你一定要達到這樣大賺
小賠的一個模式
就是賠的時候可能賠一點點
但賺的時候儘量有一個大的
這樣子一個波段
或大的一個空間
我今天剛好有帶我的新書來
你的新書
你也有新書
對 這個技術班的書
送給兩位主持人
哎呀哎呀
對
哎呦 等一下
接骨特訓班
我們今天要幫骨科
take的東西相當多
接骨什麼
接骨就是骨頭斷掉的話
要把它接起來的意思
對啊 接骨啊
骨科大夫的接骨特訓班
剛剛好像有無意間聽到
這一本就是要兩萬八
這一本要兩萬八
那我們要回送
回送骨科什麼
對
就是今天晚上8點請你幫我見證
哈哈哈哈
還有一場全面
好 謝謝谷歌大夫
肌股特訓班全彩的
對 全彩的
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕